how's it going everybody it's Warren
welcome back to my channel the cosmic
wonder where we talk about all things
Marvel and everything relating to the
MCU and today we finally have some
official phase 4 news about Black Widow
coming directly from Marvel themselves
recently it was revealed by Scarlett
Johansson herself that Black Widow is a
standalone franchise she was very
specific when she said this she didn't
say it was a standalone movie that
exists within the MCU she said that it's
a standalone franchise confirming
essentially that there is going to be
other movies that are black widow films
but of course the big question is is
Scarlett Johansson going to continue to
play Black Widow and going to continue
to be in these films well thanks to
Marvel themselves it looks like we have
an answer and we're going to break it
down in this video but first
congratulations to one Mota
for being the winner of the Hawkeye
Funko pop giveaway last week just email
me and the email in my description and
we'll get you your Funko pop and this
week we're giving away a Thanos with the
Infinity Gauntlet Funko pop all you have
to do to enter subscribe like the video
and leave a comment down below so
director of The Black Widow movie Cate
shortland recently was interviewed by
Empire and she revealed that despite the
fact that this is probably Natasha
Romanovs last film it's only just the
beginning for Florence pues yelena
Bulova here's exactly what she had to
say in the interview with Empire
magazine Kevin Feige realized that the
audience would expect an origin story so
of course we went in the opposite
direction and we didn't know how great
Florence P would be we knew she would be
great but we didn't know how great
Scarlett is so gracious like oh I'm
handing her the baton so it's going to
propel another female storyline so this
is actually pretty big news because if
we take what Scarlett Johansson said
about the Black Widow film actually
being a franchise and not just a single
film and we take what director Kate
Shortland said we can tell that Black
Widow has a big future in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe however it's not
going to be Natasha Romanov as the
director said Natasha is going to pass
on the baton to Yelena and this is
something that we actually kind of
expected Black Widow has always been a
pretty important character in the comics
and although this isn't going to be a
Natasha Romanov
Widow Florence Pugh is said to be
amazing and it sounds like she's going
to do an excellent job at becoming the
new Black Widow which we'll see happen
in the film now another big thing that
this reveals is that obviously Florence
pees character Jelena Bulova isn't going
to die there was a lot of talk for a
while because there was a very
particular scene in the final trailer
for The Black Widow film that looked
like Natasha was saying goodbye to
Yelena because Yelena was about to die
but clearly if Natasha is going to be
passing on the baton to Yelena she's not
going to die at least not in the first
black widow film and we know Natasha's
not going to die because well we know
when she does die but it does seem like
there's going to be a lot of emotion in
the Black Widow film and it's going to
kick off a franchise that's going to
start lawrence Pugh as a new Black Widow
so let me know what you think about this
let me know what you think about
Florence pews character Jelena Bulova
becoming the new Black Widow and a new
franchise are you excited about this
will you miss Natasha let me know what
you think down below don't forget to
like this video and subscribe if you'd
like to stay up to date on everything
happening in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe for live updates you can follow
me on Twitter and as always thank you
all so much for watching
woof woof